ben ouais j'ai dit attention vers des
distances ou là je sais que vous avez
envie de me sentirais bien sûr en
opération camouflage
il y aura la deuxième partie de son
c'est pas ta meuf là-bas et wim de
l'erika mais elle a fait procède ces
machines gagner votre collègue aussi qui
le fera effectivement ben voilà c'est
vrai surtout on a la garde a mis trop
tellement plus bien sûr est en ce moment
à la télé il ya une série que je kiffe
moi aussi ma chérie qui touche bientôt à
sa fin
ça s'appelle les élections america s'est
mis un chalet mais bon sens a confié les
derniers épisodes
vous allez voir je vais faire un petit
récap précédemment dans les élections
américaines
alors c'est l'histoire de deux
américains avec des prénoms biens
américains d'allant et joey ces deux
mecs qui aiment pas trop trop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cool à jour
quand joe apprend que normalement ma il
est président il fait le petit message à
d'honneur sauf que donald lui il y croit
encore il fait même la danse de la
victoire plumaugat du bon score
bien sûr que moore ap sauf dans la bulle
sur le prato chiffres mais ça plaît pas
trop fan de joe et deux y sont pas
contents du coup donald pas forcément il
est colère et les fans de joe et sont
partis en batch et donald pour les
montres un truc
[Applaudissements]
alors je vais pas vous spoiler la fin de
la série mais bon donne après tout ça il
n'est pas au top de sa forme
[Applaudissements]
toutes les personnes qui ont les règles
autres ceux qui ont des tripes double
feinte luigi vidéo est très grasse
énergie très bon aussi mon luigi mon
chéri ya du sepa tabac pouvoir un peu le
principe est exactement donc le principe
ça vous a plu
c'est à dire c'est comme si ça c'est pas
bien c'est très simple on appelle des
gens pour jouer en couple en fait on va
isoler la jeune fille qui est en couple
avec le jeune homme
et on va habiller une personne de notre
production exactement pareil que la
jeune fille est là le mec va voir sa
meuf en train de galoches un autre mec
c'est ça mon l'outil exactement si vous
avez ce truc justement les mêmes
manteaux les mêmes bonnes et je vois
qu'avant ça vous vous réveillez vous en
coûtera ici
[Rires]
[Musique]
et je suis avec abou et diana ça les
gars ça lui fait qu'on attend vous êtes
ensemble sept mois alors on est là pour
jouer pour un bon cadeau de 100 euros
attention c'est pas mal parce que je
sais c'est que je commence à me poser
des questions je laisse aller se mettre
sur le côté bon pas entendu réponse
évidemment on commence c'est quoi le
petit surnom qui te donne dans
l'intimité petit chat petit chat oui il
dit quoi yahoo son film préféré jeu
lui-même senti prêt doit hasard comme ça
[Rires]
[Musique]
ce à dire eh bien j
tu as bien manger mon petit chat
[Musique]
pression tu connais les dernières
vacances que mes fait ensemble c'était
ou bas on n'est pas parti en vacances en
france
ça fait maintenant déjà 20 noms quand
vous habitez par sandra du coup non non
non ok c'est quoi son plus gros défaut
dans son plus gros défaut girerd
possessif et jaloux je vois les jaloux
verts ale jalousie à toi t'es jaloux un
peu aussi pour atteindre
quel est pour toi de toi c'est pas ta
meuf
[Musique]
mais honnêtement après mon père l'acteur
qu'elle aime bien où elle dit à chaque
fois allumé est trop mignon elle aucune
idée non à la chorale un chanteur qui
aime bien vous connaissez vous voulez
que je vous présente la qualité que tu
préfères elle a du coeur c'est ça qui
est important
ah ouais c'est important et a tracé pour
ta meuf là
tahar est lourd
[Musique]
ah non c'était fait
vous êtes rencontrés comment sur
internet ok très bien c'est quoi son
petit déjeuner préféré des biscottes le
prénom de sa meilleure copine damaye le
bateau neuf
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais non
[Musique]
une pression les deux comédiens qui vous
a ils se ressemblent pas will 60 sont
payés en faire ça mais ils sont vraiment
samba sow redit que le début de la
journée s'est passé
[Applaudissements]